but yeah i mean like i don't really know
what else to say about the cougs that's
that's why the cougs is on there if you
want to have a good band hey yeah it's
it's it's a good bat it's a good indie
band okay so a lot of these
uh so a lot of these a lot of bands i
wanted to put on were of course indie
bands especially a lot of indie bands
from england i guess because i did i did
go through i think the the period of
life in my life where i went where i
listened to the most music is probably
in like between high school and
university where i listened to a lot of
[ __ ] indie bands
um and a lot of that was because i was
actually in a band myself i don't i
don't know if i were you yeah i don't
know if i've ever talked about this no
you've never tried we've never talked
about have i never mentioned never
obviously right on guitar and i'll just
like film whatever happens there's
always the prince you can do everything
else
have i never mentioned this before no
i've never mentioned this you've
mentioned that you used to play guitar
like a little bit this feels like
something you should mention more yeah
this feels like a personality trait i
feel betrayed that you haven't mentioned
this yeah i mean um i guess like okay so
i i guess i gotta get to get into this
story then okay let's okay let's let's
let's let's start right at the beginning
i'm actually gonna say that you were a
member of the cooks
he was a platinum-selling artist
so i i guess the reason i wanted to
learn how to play guitar in the first
place is my first choice on that it's
muse
um i remember the first time hearing
plug-in baby and just hearing that riff
oh and like just gone like something
just clicked in my mind and i was just
like i need to be able to play this
and i
i need to be able to play this and like
i remember before like my um my mom had
always tried to get me to learn guitar
because she's just like you know people
play guitar oh cool you know my mum
thinks it's cool and i'm just like she
set me for like guitar lessons as a kid
and i never really took them seriously
right i was just like i'm doing this
because my mom wants me to do it right i
can play [ __ ] oasis wonder wall
whatever the [ __ ] you know
which i would argue is the only song you
need to know yeah the only song you need
to know okay i was just like whatever
and i only we only owned a acoustic
guitar at the time yeah and then i went
uh i remember i went into secondary
school which is like just
i guess just before high school age in
in the uk or is it high school age i
don't know secondary school yeah um and
i remember the first time hearing
plug-in baby and i was just like why did
they never teach us how to play this in
[ __ ] guitar lessons what the [ __ ] i i
i know how to play a bar code a bar
chord sorry
um i'd like like what what do i need to
do to learn how to play this and so the
first thing i did was i uh did your
acoustic yeah i ditched my acoustic i
signed up for guitar lessons uh in my in
my secondary school and i was like
mother i would like an electric guitar
did she get you one huh did she get you
one uh she i remember we we got like a
like a [ __ ] cheap ass electric guitar
basics not even amazon basics i got one
lap that was like on like a car boot
sale or something like that
which which was what i would do the
trick yeah yeah that was that did the
trick so
um so i can't remember what my first
guitar was it was it was it was a [ __ ]
guitar it was it was one where i had to
like replace all of the [ __ ] strings
on the guitar because all of the strings
were like rusted already
didn't like at that point i didn't even
know how to like properly tune or uh or
like change the strings of a guitar so
like my teacher at the time had to uh
teach me how to do it but uh yeah i mean
um that's when i that's like that's when
i first look properly got into learning
how to play the guitar um and uh and at
that point as
the point where i was building up my
skill level to uh you know be able to
play plug-in baby which eventually i did
yeah and uh and then i actually now that
i think about it once i learned how to
play plug-in baby i that my drive to
like improve my skill level just kind of
just stopped so i have reached peak
like yeah you never need to play you
know when i like you know when you've
reached the goal you set for yourself
and i just never found a next goal to
set for myself so like for me it was
just like play guitar to play plug-in
baby i can do it now mother i can stop
playing the guitar now oh my god dispose
on this
i always wanted to play guitar hero more
than
yeah so uh yeah and then so then in that
time uh one of my friends he he wanted
to start a band and i was like you know
what why not i've i've got nothing
better to do at this time you know i'm
uh i can play the guitar might as well
use it for some first day lessons do you
know plugging me
a little stuff
yeah
um and so yeah i mean i joined because i
wasn't doing really doing anything with
the guitar aside from trying to learn
how to play plug in baby so i'm just
like maybe i'll just join the guitar
maybe i'll just join a band for fun yeah
um and i mean i don't think we were the
greatest band but
did you ever play yeah yeah we played
like a bunch of gigs actually i got like
what yeah yeah i've like i think the
biggest crowd we played in front of in
was
kind of like 500 to a thousand people
what what okay okay
oh my god how have you never told the
story okay so
okay so i remember when we were trying
to think of the band name i i think we
have like a [ __ ] stupid bad name
they're always stupid
our band name we we like
we like try to like brainstorm a bunch
of [ __ ] band names and like nothing
just seemed to click because nothing
everything sounded either like too metal
or you know too campy or whatever
uh and then we just went on we just went
with the name nine and a half pounds
because
uh because the month before my mate uh
one of the lead singer went on a diet
and he lost nine and a half pounds and
that was like we were just like you know
what we don't know what we're going to
call our bands let's just use this as
just the name until we think of the
actual name for the band and then that
just
that was just like that's amazing as
with a lot of names you know uh you you
just sticks right you pick a filler i
mean you're just like can't be asked to
change it now
so you would just like play
any song what kind of songs did you play
um so i'm used that just means no i mean
uh we wrote our own songs oh um so we'd
go uh so my mate had uh we we uh we went
to the drummer's house because uh my the
our drama always gather at the drama you
always gather the drama sounds cause you
can bring your [ __ ] guitar you can
bring your you know you can bring your
you can bring your bass or whatever to
someone's house you can't you can't
transport a drum kit yeah you know what
i mean so um at first we went to the
drummer's house to practice and then and
write songs and eventually we had like
this really like
this really like [ __ ] old music
studio that suck that a friend of a
friend of her friends yeah dad owned you
know you know that kind of kind of thing
and you walk in it's like a back alley
and like the [ __ ] door hinges like
like broken in like 10 million times or
something and you're like i might get
stabbed here but they have a drum kit
and a recording studio right so whatever
that's just amazing and i remember the
biggest uh the biggest gig we played
was like we signed up to what was the
equivalent of like a battle of the bands
kind of kind of kind of deal bro you had
an anime arc yeah so so okay so like
this is just this is just back
no part of the reason why
i got so into back and why beck was one
of my like my favorite you say this when
you're talking about ben yeah i think i
did mention it i must have mentioned it
i would remember if you were like yeah
by the way i was in a battle abandoned i
think i would remember the name nine and
a half pounds okay
okay so we were just a band for fun we
weren't taking this seriously
um but like we we met like a lot of
bands who were like [ __ ] amazing that
came out of our school because like i
guess part of the other reason why we
formed a band was because we are the
school i went to was a performing arts
school so a lot of people there were
doing
were doing performing arts whether it
was theater or music or something so
there were like some people in my school
like my classmates who were taking like
music really really seriously right we
were just like whatever i'm learning
guitar i i'll just play i'll just play
in the band because whatever that seems
like a cool way to spend my time um and
so
i remember for this battle of the bands
we literally had to like audition to get
into this battle of bands right and it
was like it was a pretty big deal at the
time because this gig was pretty famous
for like a lot of students and there was
like
there was sometimes there would even be
people from music labels who would
attend like events like this yeah
so we weren't like we weren't expecting
anything to come out of this we were
just like you know what they're holding
auditions at our school and we could
sign up so we're just like what have we
got to lose we didn't really we didn't
really expect anything because we didn't
really think that we were that good of
bands right uh so we obviously we
obviously auditioned um and it was
literally like the [ __ ] x factor kind
of thing kind of deal right because the
big golden buzzer in the middle yeah
yeah because literally we uh because
because our school was a performing arts
so we had like a theater set up right
and the theater we had like a drum kit
in the middle and we had there there
were judges on there oh wow and uh we
had to uh we had to play two songs right
we had to play two songs in front of the
judges and i remember god plays plug and
baby and the crowd goes wild sorry and
now for our second song plugging baby
one more time the montage starts
everyone gets up on there okay yeah
and then uh i i remember we were like we
were hearing some of our [ __ ] some of
the other bands that were playing before
us yeah and we were just like
[ __ ] my life we gotta follow these guys
we gotta follow these guys what the [ __ ]
yeah
and so and so i remember thinking we're
not gonna get on because there were a
lot of other bands that were [ __ ]
better than us i'm gonna say that yeah
but so we went on uh we we just we just
played our songs you know the the the
judges you know waved us off whatever we
didn't expect much and so
we didn't get into the battle of the
bands we actually became like a backup
choice just in case
just in case you know okay uh
and so we went on with our lives and
then we get a call like a week before
the event and went out
and they were just like uh so one of the
one of the bands is dropped out and we
got an extra space in this battle of the
bands concerts um do you wanna do you
wanna come on and we're like what the
[ __ ] this this is literally carol on
tuesday like that's exactly what
happened in carolina
it's an anime
and so we were just like i mean yes but
how the [ __ ] can we prepare in a week
yeah for this battle of the bands which
is which is like other bands have
prepared for for like a good month or
two you know like like
playing with a band is [ __ ] more much
more difficult than you imagined it if
you've never played in the band before
uh because you're in a live setting
right and a lot of things can go wrong
and you need to be on the same
wavelength as your other band members
i've played plenty of gigs and some
games are better than others sometimes
you make mistakes and sometimes you know
you you're not in sync with the rest of
the band and you need you know you need
to be tight you need like the
performance needs to be tight
so you need a lot of practice so uh we
said yes but we didn't really
we didn't really have time to practice
the songs that we wanted to practice
right um but there was like well that
was like one joke song that we had
practiced uh
we had practiced before because we
didn't really have any gigs coming up
and it was i just had sex
no no it's it was an indie rock version
of hit me baby one more time
by britney spears that's [ __ ] awesome
it was it was it was hit me baby one
more time by honey spears hell yeah and
and we were just like well we don't
really have time to practice some of our
more complicated songs so let's just put
that in the set whatever whatever right
um and i remember we had the
conversation before of um we always
wanted the experience of like having the
audience you know i having the audience
sing part of the song yeah like like a
lot of bands yeah of course and
uh and i remember we were having this
discussion of you know the perfect point
of this song would be uh what's what's
the line um
how does it mean baby one more time go
again
i think he's thinking about the chorus
right yeah yeah uh with me baby one more
time no no no no no no no
no no here it is
it was it's when the line goes my
loneliness it's killing me yeah and uh
yeah and we were saying that would be an
awesome point for like the audience like
chime in but like we were just to do the
end to do the entire because that would
be that that would be like an awesome
feeling yeah of course but we were just
like now we're not gonna do it because
like what's more embarrassing than like
stopping because then stopping a song
letting the audience sing
and no one sings like we we did not have
the [ __ ] balls
right um and so i remember
i remember we we we go to the battle of
the bands and it's like the biggest
audience so far normally we're used to
performing for like 50 to 100 people so
this was like a lot which is which is
still a lot you know we're just a lot
but like this was like about 500 people
it was that like
it was like concord 2 which uh if you
know in uh if if you know brighton congo
is actually one like one of the biggest
venues that's not like the brighton
that's like that's not the bright the
main brighton venue it's like a lot of
big indie bands go there um
and so
uh we go on stage and we're just like
guys we're not gonna take this seriously
a lot of these bands are [ __ ] amazing
we're just gonna have fun we're just so
anime we're just we're just going to
have fun right um and i remember so we
go on stage we play the set and
this is this is me like playing on pure
adrenaline so we're so we're not
practiced at all we're not as tight as
we want to be in terms of our
performance but
i
seeing like for some reason just like
playing in front of like the biggest
crowd kind of like hyped us up and i
can't really explain the feeling but it
just like something that day just
clicked you know you know you know some
days where you're just like in the zone
like that day for some reason all of us
were just in the zone we were like at
peak performance right yeah and then i i
remember we uh we decided because
because we were going to meme it up we
decided we were going to end it on hit
me uh on hit me baby one more time yeah
uh the rest of it was just going to be
our original songs and we're going to
end it on that because we're just like
we don't care whatever yeah the audience
is probably not going to like it because
it's [ __ ] britney spears but we're
just going to have fun with it um and
then i remember when we start playing
the song somehow the audience just like
erupts right the audience because like
this is not the type of audience that
would listen to [ __ ] britney spears
yeah yeah they're here for like [ __ ]
arctic monkeys they're here for [ __ ]
block party you know like the claxsons
or so or some [ __ ] like that and and i
remember playing this song right and
obviously we had agreed that we weren't
going to stop the music with the and i
yeah right
but you saw we saw the energy in the
crap
right you had no choice and and and we
were like it was it was such a it was
one of the most surreal moments in my
life right where we had this we had this
performance where we were just all like
in this
we were in flow you know we were just in
in like we were like kuroko basket in
the zone and i remember i remember the
the moment was coming up right
i looked over i looked like i went to
the drama that's so animated
cause i remember i was just i was like i
want to do this but we have we we agreed
that we wouldn't and i remember i i
remember thinking i want to do this and
i remember looking at the drummer and he
had like the same look as i did
i looked over the basis and the bass is
just like
oh my god
and and then and he nodded at me and
then uh and then i i looked over to the
singer and in the corner
he sees me on the corner of my eye uh at
the corner of his eye and i'm just like
and then he nods back and i'm just like
okay it's going to happen and so and so
it goes my loneliness is killing me
silence
and i and like the [ __ ] entire like
concert hall just like [ __ ] they
complete the line and it's just like i
can't explain that [ __ ] feeling it it
is it's better than saying it is like it
is like the biggest orgasm i've had in
my life like
poor sydney
because because it was i don't know it
was it was kind of like a disney moment
for me because like somehow everything
just [ __ ] came together and then we
just we continued the song and it was
the best like the best reaction that
we've ever got from a crowd
um
so the battle of the bands was done by
votes and there were 10 bands there we
came in third oh [ __ ] did you get
anything any prizes no we didn't get any
prizes we didn't get any prizes but that
that would get the biggest orgasm of his
life yeah that was that was the peak of
my of music career that was that was the
peak of my music career
it all went down i mean that's pretty
ridiculous considering this what how
many [ __ ] hundreds of bands that have
probably never experienced that true and
that from that day onward he uh
relinquished the name grant
and became gone
he wasn't right to use the name leveled
up and evolved yeah i can't use the name
anymore that that's great how the [ __ ]
have you never brought this out i never
brought this up i don't i just i swear
i've said i've been in a band before and
no one's ever just
everyone's been in the band before not
everyone's been in a painting before oh
yeah i've been in a band for like 10
seconds until i realized it's a horrible
idea
yeah i don't know i mean yeah that's why
i really liked back because i looked at
beck and i'm just like [ __ ] i get that
that's my life so you were like actually
good at guitar
i was like competent at guitar well you
played in front of people that's pretty
good i mean i played in front of people
but
i mean that's
my mind that's pretty good so we're
starting a band called ten and a half
pounds soon
ten and a half hours i look forward to a
guy who's like unlocked memories in me
like i heard the [ __ ] zelda
thing when you were like i i remember i
tried to learn guitar well i tried but i
think my parents nudged me towards it
right i just remember being in in
someone's house playing guitar trying to
do twinkle twinkle little star right and
i just was like i don't know
i said i don't get this and then he was
like gave me this device that was a
tuner but i don't know what it did he
was like you got to do it until it goes
green the light yeah i was like
why
it all sounds the same
it all sounds very similar
it's just one beep to one another and my
parents bought this tuna for me and i
remember just even at that time i was
like eight i was like
my parents just wasted their money on
this channel i'm never gonna get good at
this
so i've never never learned guitar and
then i remember i went to learn drums
which seems pretty fitting for me
because i'm you know you just need a
sense of rhythm yeah just like hand eye
coordination which is great i've had
great hand-eye coordination
unfortunately no rhythm so
that that was the crux of that one and
that was over with and i never really
learned drums i went for like a year and
i've never really learned anything
really they try to make they try to
teach me how to read the sheet music
that's where i was like no yeah i don't
want to do this
jazz drumming methods yeah yeah i i
think i i stopped learning at the point
where
sheet music started to become like a
thing of my lessons i'm just like i
don't like this anymore
this used to be fun when we were just
talking about beeps and boobs now you
brought reading into this yeah
that's why i draw the line yeah because
like i like
like like i think we said this last time
where i go by i go by feeling like and
and that's what i went when i wrote like
a protagonist because i don't understand
a single thing about [ __ ] music
theory you know i know which chords
sound nice in my head and sometimes i
have like a nice like like beat or
rhythm in my head and i'm just like
let's try to play this out guitar i i do
not know what [ __ ] you're literally from
like like 100 like in the way you think
it's like 100 it's the exact same like i
can't read [ __ ] i just feel and i can
play i remember at one point i uh
for some reason one of my friends was
like yeah we need a singer i was like
all right i'll do it then i'll do it
i'll do it yeah i i couldn't sing at all
right i didn't have any confidence in it
the first song i'm not even kidding the
first song that we had to learn is the
only one i ever bothered learning yeah
yeah we never did anything this this
died by this song guess what song we had
to sing
museum no it's [ __ ] smash mouth
[Laughter]
i remember like actually why did you not
pursue it i have like very vivid
memories of me actually seriously trying
to learn how to sing yeah [ __ ]
all-star before it was a meme right
right right and i when this came when
this became a huge meme i was like this
is like i had like nam flashbacks like
just like oh my god oh my god this is
the song
i i need to hear an actual serious cover
of smash mouths all stuff karaoke yeah
because every time every time we go to
karaoke of course all star comes up
at least four or five times throughout
the night and every time it's just kind
of singing like a dumb voice i want i
want you to actually like
be serious and like try
if i seriously try and sing yeah i feel
vulnerable
i feel
criticism i can't do it no no no i won't
if i'm the clown it's safe no no no no
no no no safety i get that corner i get
that i'm bad at something you can't hide
you can't oh hi now that you've said
that you hide behind my clown makeup
thank you very much now that you've said
that you have to do that what was your
first pick
that was my first picture
oh my god it's been like four hours